[Applause]
all right sports [ __ ] with pop in
yo it's mad sports [ __ ] carson tyree
still being annoying yeah i'm
that motherfucker's annoying bro you
think you think kevin durant is over it
yet
no but do you know what the context of
the quote was was so lebron was like
this hurt me that kyrie said this on a
podcast with kevin durant
kyrie said normally i feel like i'm the
best person to take the last shot at the
end of the game because i'm
essentially because i'm the best shot
maker yeah this is the first time i've
looked at it like
he can do every shot i can do and he can
make it look easier about kevin durant
which i don't think is kind of scary and
lebron was like i'm so hurt by that i
always try to build up kyrie blah blah
blah lebron was
kind of a hoe about it
do you think it's because uh larsa
pippen has been sucking them all off
do you think that's the reason super
sweet she is a super spreader bro that
girl is 40 years old
virus and her legs bro she out here
getting decked
wait she's good lebron that he wasn't
mentioning kyrie's
lebron was mad that he wasn't mentioned
no lebron was mad
that um i apologize to everybody
listening right now
lebron is mad because uh
kyrie said in an interview a while ago
that now for the first time in his
career
he finally has someone who he feels as
confident as himself taking the last
shot
lebron was like yo fam we're on the same
team like i didn't know that you didn't
think i could hit shots
lebron is so [ __ ] yeah yo
talk that [ __ ] taylor i've been told you
that though i just feel like
i like lebron outside of the court i
don't like him on like
because interesting he's sensitive about
basketball but like when it comes to
real life stuff you like where he steps
up yeah
why do you think why do i think that
yeah
because i seen him play and he's [ __ ]
like he tries to
i don't like it he cries about
everything he cries about a lot of his
calls yes
like he plays like a soccer player
well that is an insult international
appeal
international appeal same thing
no but for real yeah he kind of a whiny
dude yeah is that y'all just noticing
that yeah
i don't like whining bro yeah i think
it's a whining thing i don't like
[ __ ] whining dude go out there get
your [ __ ] done
simple as that i mean that's lebron if
you've been the best since you were 18
everything goes your way i mean maybe
not his whole life but like
like uh professionally professionally
yeah your whole life
you just kind of expect things to kind
of go your way but you also have oh
he's all sorry he's also a little
passive aggressive he's just like that's
his way it's savvy media wise to be like
oh
i was so generous to kyrie i told him
you'll be mvp blah blah he's a talented
kid
the kid the kid the kid but it's mad
passive aggressive it's strategic
but that seems to be how he operates and
i get how great he is but that is
annoying
yeah yeah but if you're if you're kyrie
you just gotta take that [ __ ]
like you are the kid you know i'm saying
like you are
this is lebron james this is the
greatest player of his generation and
y'all are hooping together
and he [ __ ] with you but you're not
lebron well no in that case though i'm
like yo i'm trying to compliment
my teammate i'm not trying to dog you
out you are better he never says i was
the best player
he said i could hit the last shot we all
kind of agree with that i think yeah
loki maybe this is maybe this is kyrie
just trying to statement
it's not the wrong saying but maybe this
is kyrie trying to guess kd
that's what i thought it was and trying
to let kd know hey
i'm gonna be the number two here don't
get it twisted i know what you do that's
what i thought it was
he said we're going to be one together
because he didn't say someone could make
it better than me he's like he could
make it and make it look easier yeah we
still going to make it
yeah yeah fair enough but
when it was kyrie lebron though who was
taking the last shot
i really hit the last shot i mean
there's still a 58 seconds left or
whatever so it wasn't like two seconds
left but so lebron has been mad
clutch towards the end of his career
like in the beginning
but he has been unreal clutch like so
many yeah
absolutely he's not not clutch i just
think kyrie is good in those moments
he's like yeah if you got one person you
want to take the shot kyrie has an
infinite amount of moves lebron's got
bully ball and he's got that step to the
side three
yeah that's what it is uh yeah it's not
that crazy people just need [ __ ] to talk
about so they talk about it and lebron
did you and what bothered me he was like
when i read the transcript of his
comments like you went through the whole
comments and still thought it was an
insult
he said like i took it in context so
that makes it even seem more like
oh he's not just taking a sound bite
he's upset with the full context
i think lebron just wants to be put with
the greats like kobe and mike
he is yeah but he's a different he's not
kobe and mike though they're like
different genes but you could compare
kobe to mike
more than you could compare lebron to
yeah i think lebron is
a better player than kobe but kobe is
more jordan yeah it's not that crazy you
don't even react like that
no i do i do how dare you
this is such a strong reaction yeah you
did react but she grew up you grew up
next you grew up
even though i was like even if i didn't
eat
this girl don't even know what a tunnel
is bro that's how it works
you don't even live near a tunnel you're
like what would i do in that i only fly
via private jet
yeah my chauffeur takes me around
exactly the windows on the limbo are so
tinted i can't even see the wrong [ __ ]
oh god
you are so bougie dude it's unbelievable
how blue you are
yeah you are mad you changed bro you got
your hair i missed the old taylor
remember when we had remember we had the
other chair
remember we had the other chair we had
that leather chair yeah and then she's
like i need something more
plush yeah she did i need something more
look at her now
in the fuchsia goddamn seashell we gave
her a [ __ ] seashell this year
we had to buy a whole new [ __ ] chair
[Laughter]
so the point is taylor you got to stop
being so bougie oh this is flaring too
okay out here we're chilling this is
like we're just regular blue-collar
americans like
you out here bougie as [ __ ] yeah you got
a
a purse hanging off your mic like all
you do is shop
name brand look at your [ __ ] computer
it's made out of snake skin
that's crazy what's going on you're
wearing a scarf it's 90 [ __ ] degrees
inside
how bougie is she this girl's so
booze just be regular like
us yeah hard-working americans that's it
no we're not done and the question she
asks
is crazy like why would people build
things
just get mexicans to
you death so [ __ ] up dude oh is his
name
dubbed like he doesn't look like a dog
that's how it sounds here i sound like a
white girl you are so busy yeah
dude you are so busy about it like
it's crazy it's really crazy dude you
know
we come back to that really i'm in i'm
an alliance
why do you make me sound like i'm one of
the girls from clueless you that's what
you honestly sound like
yo that's how much you think you're
above us
you know that's facts bro you know
that's fine though
you see you don't like your hair you
flipped your hair yo
you are so boozy you don't even think
she's a human being that's how much you
think she's above us
oh my god bro i can't possibly relate to
you
[ __ ] mongrels oh my you humans
yuck whoa dude that part might be true
actually i know i see it
i think it i can't believe i don't even
know what to say
with snoop dogg and you that's another
[ __ ] oh i smoked
i got the video right now i remember
when i smoked was oh you guys didn't do
that oh weird
yeah oh my gosh
oh you guys didn't hang out with kobe
when he was younger
i'm the one that bought his backyard
hoops i'm the one that's in my driveway
i told him how to play ball
yo that is crazy when you said you
taught kobe how to play ball yeah that's
why
that was [ __ ] tricky because like the
age is all off like it don't even make
sense but the fact that you even said
that
and you got the mamba case for the
[ __ ] computer
this is crazy purple mamba that's
[ __ ] nuts
jeez yo taylor we gotta bring you back
down
we have to bring her back down to earth
yeah
i'm waiting to leave earth actually oh
yeah yeah
where he's gonna go let's go in a tunnel
probably
that's crazy i'm really trying to go
back to my planet but what is your
planet planets
you want a saturn no first of all
it's cause it's red no no oh that's not
saturn because you got rings on it
because you like jewelry um
bougie s oh there you go you're the one
that's bushes that brought your wife
or your fiance now um ice skating ring
yeah you're right you're right right
you're right you boys bougie too i
didn't say i wasn't bougie also
okay i'm working class bougie though oh
you're working closely
with collarbone i still got a collar
yeah i mean i hate one of these
misfits in a [ __ ] t-shirt
and reservations all over town come on
bro we in the different restaurants
they got clothing requirements but i was
gonna say that my planet
is under
we had enough dude honestly we had
enough time to take a stand
we got to take a stand against you bro
you're acting crazy
you are a crazy-ass girl what'd you say
literally when you walked in today
she walked into our show we could start
now i didn't yeah
you could start now yeah sorry literally
it was [ __ ] up
akash was still out there doing a day
shift at dunkin donuts
it was still working bro all the lattes
you know what i mean yeah him and doug
and i was working hard they're working
with you make him get the dunkin donuts
i don't make him he goes and get himself
yeah
that's a good point all right i give you
that yeah that's decent
taylor i swear to god taylor you you are
you are pushing every one of my last
buttons
i swear to god you know this girl is
pushing my butt like a kid on an
elevator
just pushing all of them that's right
that's what you do
i love doing that let's move on
not enough what else we got
you